john gray looks to follow up not only on
what her mod did
a short while ago but on uh what he did
in his last doubting
boy that was that was vintage john gray
yeah you're talking about the five
innings
no runs the 10 strikeouts no walks john
gray yeah that's what he did he's now
third all time
in rocky's history with 752
career strikeouts but what i want for
him today is to get that w to get number
50 of his career
hit out to deep center field off the
wall and
something the pirates hadn't done yet in
this series an extra base hit
a triple to start for frasier so the
pirates who have not scored a run
in the first 18 innings of this series
of a man a third and nobody
out and that should do it blackman
fraser tagging
and just got in there on a good throw by
blackman the sac fly for hayes the
pirates lead one nothing
reynolds coming to bat against gray he
does
slammed out to right center brian
reynolds hits one out of coors field
home run number 14 and the pirates are
up two to nothing
that's what you're looking for you're in
that cow early in the ball game nobody
on base
2-0 look for something that you could
drive and boy did he ever drive that
450 feet numbers for chad cool
two and four of 505 era
pitching much better of late better
command better results he's seven hits
in his last 12 innings where he gave up
two runs through two starts
after the fastball away the slider down
and then striking out tapia to start
well an infield hit for hampson here is
charlie blackman
good slider to strike him out he faces
cj
crone now that's a nice slide piece
from mr cool he's got three strikeouts
in the first inning
this is the shortstop kevin newman one
guy
will be tom that we said he got a hit
rogers throws across one out he's gotten
two outs here's kai
tom swung on him
one two three in the second for the gray
wolf and that's his third strikeout one
ball two strike count on joshua fuentes
joshua fuentes
[Applause]
that'll be reynolds that wants it and
there's the second out
first and second here is john gray the
colorado rockies pitcher
and cool does get the strikeout so odds
are two left for colorado
two ahead the pirates are the pirates
have two on with two outs
three two and he got the strikeout on
the slider a couple walks couple bent
left
middle of three pirates two rockies
nothing top of the order coming a one
out
single for garrett hampton it brings up
charlie blackmon who struck out in the
first
um or is it about the same oh right back
to the mound beautiful
shows that up nicely one to six to three
a double play with chad cool on the
mound that's been the theme lately
oh one out base runner for the pirates
in the fourth they lead it two to
nothing and here's
michael perez the catcher 2-2
easy play first for cj crow moving to
third is newman
two outs they will intentionally walk
tom to get cool to the plate
very next pitch cool obliges by
grounding out to third
the heart of the order krone and mcmahon
and rogers
in the rockies half of the fourth this
ball is
launched to deep left and it is
gone rocky's on the board cj crone with
his 11. and that snaps it over
16. we just missed a double his first
time up before he ended up striking out
this time
no worries here's the 1-2 pitch swinging
a miss high fastball
blue 96 little upstairs the pitch runner
goes swinging a pop-up off to the right
slamming his back down fuentes
frustrated but look out and it's caught
casually over the shoulder grab by adam
frazier
like it was nothing taking a sunday
stroll out there puts it away
had it all the way on dom nunez left
hand hitting catcher walked in the
second
little tapper evans
gets the final out thrown with the home
run ben gamil the hitter
here ground ball to second that's got it
pulls it to his chest
in the inning reynolds walked he's left
to board john through the fifth inning
one run game
garrett hampson has half of the rockies
hits
base hit right field topia will come
around
we're all leaving it too and a double
for garrett hanson have an afternoon
g ham so cj crone first and third
one out go ahead run at third in
hampstead blackman at first and this
ball
is lifted to left center field should be
deep enough
here's reynolds getting underneath it to
throw in the direction of second rockies
have a 3-2
lead as hanson slides home base is
loaded for fuentes
0-2 called third strike the rockies
score
two they leave the bases loaded and
after five
now colorado three pittsburgh too kevin
newman
pirate shortstop this ball is well hit
to left
top fakes the catch
how much has his outfield play improved
this year
they talked about it earlier in the game
on the line drive
off the bat of michael perez this time
off the bat of kevin newman
same thing time in the league and it's
hard when you're running
and then trying to jump at the same time
as you're running and you don't get the
same height
john's appreciative two outs perez at
the plate
they just ended it recently yeah
right field charlie's got it one two
three inning for gray just nine pitches
rymel a left-handed batter will
be his first man
up the middle basin doesn't matter dog
cuts the bag
at third rockies have the two run
advantage robot
tapia coming through here's garrett
hampson having a perfect day
hard down the left pass
and that in all likelihood will be his
third career
four hit ball game it should be with
with hayes having to dive for this ball
rogers will go down to second nunez to
first
and dazzle will get to hit for the
pitcher kinley
and uh base hit to right here comes
rogers hope greg
will score moving the second now the
throw to the play
out of the plate nunez tried to score on
the throw to second
so he's cut down the rockies get a sixth
run
it'll leave it up to adam frazier to try
and keep things alive for the pirates
he's got a ball game over the deal
gets out number 27 and the rockies have
swept the pirates
they come from behind and when it's six
to two